[Música]
y llegamos directo hasta china porque la
llegada de la nueva variante su variante
del cómic 19 mucho más contagiosa vuelve
a encender las alarmas ante posibles
nuevos brotes en el país donde ya
empezaron a tomar medidas adrián
foncillas desde beijing nos reporta
sobre la situación actual de esta
pandemia
si uno contaba semanas atrás apenas unas
docenas de casos diarios y hoy va por
los 300 son unas cifras ridículas si las
comparamos con las magnitudes globales
pero que aquí bastan para desatar todas
las alarmas la mayoría de casos han sido
localizados en la provincia oriental de
anhui pero también en ciudades que ya
habían pasado por cuarentenas es el caso
de shanghai que hoy contaba 24 casos son
el triple de los de ayer y además dos de
ellos están fuera de los centros de
cuarentena y en distritos diferentes lo
que hace temer que si el brote no se
controla con celeridad podría ordenarse
otro encierro por el momento se han
ordenado tests masivos en nueve de los
16 distritos de la ciudad y se han
cerrado todos los karaokes porque en uno
de ellos fue localizado el brote también
hay casos en xian la ciudad conocida por
los guerreros de terracota y son casos
de la última su variante o microbe a-52
que es la más contagiosa de todas y que
después de haberse extendido por el
mundo ha llegado al fin china el
presidente sí sin pin aclaró
recientemente que el país seguirá fiel a
la fórmula del copy 0 porque unos costes
económicos temporales son preferibles a
la pérdida de vidas humanas y
precisamente aunque varios países en el
mundo ya relajaron dos medidas para
combatir y kobe 19 china no deja de lado
la política de salud cero tolerancia de
gran foncillas no explica porque beijing
no deja de lado esta norma
si no es el único país del mundo con la
política cero cobit y la decisión se
explica a menudo como puramente política
o caprichosa la realidad sin embargo es
algo más compleja varios estudios
científicos tanto chinos como
occidentales alertan de que si china
abre la puerta al virus se podrían
producir entre 1 y 2 millones de muertos
hay dos razones que explican que china
sea especialmente frágil la primera es
la baja vacunación de los ancianos solo
el 51% de los mayores de 80 años tienen
la pauta completa y el gobierno lo ha
intentado todo desde campañas de
concienciación hasta sobornos como el
regalo de docenas de huevos descuentos
en supermercados o el pago del
equivalente de 70 dólares todo eso
inútil porque la vacuna se entiende como
un riesgo pequeño y asumible ante una
amenaza mayor que es la pandemia pero
muchos ancianos se preguntan qué peligro
conlleva un virus que solo ha matado en
china a 5000 personas sobre una
población de 1400 millones de habitantes
en más de 2 años en ese sentido china es
víctima de su propio éxito la segunda
razón es la tremenda desigualdad que hay
entre la china urbana y la rural
cualquiera que haya viajado por anhui o
por mongol interior sabe que sus
sistemas sanitarios no están preparados
para lidiar con una pandemia si el
coronavirus devastó este año hong kong
con escenas de enfermos tratados fuera
de los hospitales o de bolsas apiladas
de cadáveres que no podría hacer con la
china rural así que el gobierno le guste
o no sigue atado a la política de kobe
cero